for almost 10 years dos equis has been
engaging beer consumers with its most
interesting man in the world campaign
featuring an elegant older man recalling
mind-blowing life adventures from the
good old days those videos have made 77
year old American actor Jonathan
Goldsmith a pop-culture celebrity but in
an effort to attract a younger audience
Dos Equis recently passed the
prestigious mantle to a younger actor
Agustin lagron this Gala inventing the
descent the Queen here are a few things
you don't know about the new most
interesting man in the world
more modern at 41 at the time of his
hiring LeGrande is more than 30 years
younger than Goldsmith the new
commercials highlight the contrast right
away the previous versions basked in
past glories while vintage video footage
of his adventures plays but lagron seems
to show a more present man of mystery
Dos Equis told Adweek the new most
interesting man is a man of our times
and in this first glimpse he shares him
to being a resourceful rough-and-tumble
guy who remains a jack-of-all-trades
hero that one would expect from the man
bearing this infamous title that and
this guy was busy Ringo a master of many
tongues LeGrande is a French actor who
boasts a trilingual skill set
speaking English French and Spanish it's
interesting to note that it is Dos Equis
debut the grounds first line is actually
in Spanish mice mr. Simon the beer brand
tells USA Today there's a reason for
that saying we're trying to reach a new
audience the reality of the drinker base
is it's much more multicultural than
ever and Spanish dominant consumers are
increasingly important muy bien
as they say nearly the most boring man
before he became the new most
interesting man LeGrande almost became a
total snooze when he earned a master's
degree in tax law by a weird turn of
faith lagron was bitten by the acting
bug and enrolled at French drama school
core fluent in Paris he since been
featured on the big and small screen
since 2001 including a recurring role in
the French TV drama odysseus and the
2006 film fly boys actor and activist as
proof of his impressive moral character
lagron is also the co-founder of the
children of Don Quixote an organization
dedicated to raising awareness of
Frances homeless population beginning in
2006 the organization helped to install
110s on a canal near the cen and has
repeated the installation multiple times
over the years the grounds documentary
on the topic received an amnesty award
nomination at the Copenhagen
International Documentary Festival
he's also opened an inexpensive organic
restaurant in Paris so his real life
might be even more interesting than the
role he plays on TV new man same
narrator while there's a new most
interesting man the company still plans
on introducing the commercials with the
same narrator well Lyman his beard alone
has experienced more than a lesser man's
entire body Lyman was chosen to keep the
familiar voice going forward in lagron
zero according to brand manager Andre
Walt who said we feel he is an important
part of the campaign and while we want
to evolve what interesting means today I
think a few tenants of the brand are
very important to keep and that
apparently means keeping the same guy
who narrates the History Channel's most
questionable content deep sea UFOs
continue to lurk through the Uncharted
waters of Earth
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]